i have the pleasure of joining me right
now to my nhl player inclusion committee
teammates
that stanley cup champion kevin
shattenkirk
current member of the anaheim ducks
and also olympic champion
megan duggan
currently the manager of player
development with new jersey devils
welcome to you both good to see you
thanks for having us hanson good to see
you as well
i thought it was important to have both
you guys on and
i think both you guys thought it was
even more important than i did to have
this conversation because
we're all frustrated with our pic
over the events the last week first we
had martin luther king day junior which
we celebrated and we had the raising of
willie louise number 22 to the raptors
in boston but right after that we had
two racial incidents one
in the ahl the other one the echl that
really felt like it set our game back
why did both of you feel that was
important to have this conversation make
sure that your voices were heard
megan we'll start with you
yeah sure and and anson thanks for um
thanks for having the discussion with us
um today i think
for me i mean it's passion like i'm i
have a passion for amplifying this
message and supporting uh
you know my fellow players of color in
our sport it's it's on all of us um you
know inclusion acceptance um and it's on
us and
it's it's our game to grow and really
protect and honor
um and and i personally certainly i take
a lot of pride in in being a member of
our player inclusion committee i've
learned a lot um i've grown a lot in
being in the group
but i know myself kevin the members of
the other members of the committee
we take a lot of pride moving to action
um engaging in incidents like this here
here having our voices heard um
incidents continue like this to sadly
present themselves and
these are things that as a hockey
community we have to educate ourselves
around and we have to work to educate
others on
and when it comes to something like this
i i don't think words are enough i don't
think
posting on instagram is enough
and and personally i want to act i want
to um engage in an allyship or ants and
as we've talked about co
co-conspiracy um in order to to help act
and and move our sport away from um
incidents like this
i think
megan hit it on the head there the the
passion for the game i think is
something that we all share uh it's it's
nothing that
uh changes from
person to person color to color um male
female we all love this game for the
same reason um
but unfortunately there are certain
players who have to deal with
different obstacles uh in order to to
play the game that they love and i think
that's what we're all trying to do here
is make this
a welcoming place for anyone and i think
you know our landing our voices
hopefully shows that there are some
allies here for
uh for the black players who who
obviously had to go through that post
incidents this weekend um for females
who
are trying to break into the game and
and have to go into a locker room with
uh with a couple of young boy players in
order to just get out on the ice i think
it's it's important that they know that
we are standing by them uh that they do
have people in the sport who
support them and who are trying to
change and change our game for the
better in order for
these incidents to hopefully disappear
and never come around again
shady you're a parent and also you're
very instrumental with the players
sitting out processing a couple years
ago with fellow pic team ryan reeves and
you guys are both in the bubble
what conversations as your children
start to get older would you have with
them uh if and you know they decide to
play the game of hockey
well i i think
you know the
the way that i was raised
you know by my parents was
um
you know that we
we need to treat everyone with respect
uh you know that that's top to bottom it
doesn't matter um
what your sexual orientation is what
color you are it really uh that has no
no place in our home um and i would just
do that do just that i mean hopefully
leading by example and showing my kids
how i treat others uh is is the first
way that they see that but
um you know coming into the sport of
hockey i think hopefully they can see
uh if they do that that
um
you know i was passionate about this and
and i i always will be and it's
something that uh you know i expect of
them as well as to be
great people and i think that's that's
what this all comes down to is how do we
become great people and and better for
our community
you guys have both worn the red white
and blue the olympics are right around
the corner and mags you sit on the board
of usa hockey
how do we start to really accelerate
that growth within our grassroots of
hockey here in the united states because
we feel like it's systematic right you
see these one-offs happening all the
time but it continues to happen and it's
not going to change overnight
what do you think we should do to try to
accelerate that growth within minor
hockey
yeah um you know anson sadly we're still
seeing incidents um such as these that
we're discussing today and in the
grassroots of hockey and um you know i
think in one way um
how how we as a sport handle incidents
such as as this
how we provide
learning experiences and education um
you know to the hockey community after
incidents like this at the top
um you know we hope that that that that
shows um you know to young players
you know to the hockey ecosystem
that these types of things you know they
violate the sanctity of our game um and
and they're not they're not welcome um
and you hope that those types of things
send a message
um but in addition to that i mean i
think um
again getting into action like our group
our player inclusion committee
continuing to
get out into different spaces
in the hockey ecosystem when we can you
know within usa hockey within
all different community programs and
having these discussions you know um
bringing this type of um of of learning
experience education the training um
into locker rooms into
um boards into teams um so that
people slowly start to
understand uh how how we need to behave
as a sport um and what's tolerated and
what's not um and then you know continue
to to police these kind of things um
educate parents around it and when they
see these things in ranks uh they need
to have discussions with kids um and at
a usa hockey level you know i know that
in the last couple years
there's been things that have been done
at that level where they're trying to
increase their education and their
training around um tolerance and
inclusion and acceptance
but still have a long way to go and and
i'm certainly um you know i'm excited to
be a proud to be a part of that group in
order to keep pushing the needle and
hammering home some of this messaging
and now that you're in the hockey upside
there with the new jersey devils they're
meg's what conversations are you guys
having on the team side when it comes to
these incidents popping up all the time
because it affected
pk suban indirectly because one of his
siblings jordan was one of the people
that you know suffered from this
incident in the echo
yeah i mean similar kind of thing again
just the importance of of having
discussions bringing these things to
light talking about them uh making sure
that everyone's educated i'm proud to be
a part of the devils because i feel it's
a um you know it's an inclusive
welcoming environment um you know for me
and on my side my family i'm a gay woman
that's been invited into um you know to
hockey operations and and that's rare in
itself and so um again i think just
continuing to not shy away from having
these conversations
um and to challenging each other on the
way that we speak to each other how
um you know certain gestures are are
perceived and what they mean um you know
and i think
all of us have um you know we have a
responsibility to educate ourselves and
to educate those that we work with
and to continue to
move our sport um ahead and away from
being perceived uh as a place that's
that's not welcoming to a certain amount
of communities
and shady are you guys having these
similar conversations in the room you
guys are current players right now i
know it's easy for former players like
myself to have these conversations we
have a lot of time on our hands but as
current players you guys are currently
in the fight right now uh you guys have
these conversations paying attention
what's happening at the east coast level
in the ahl level
absolutely i think uh
this is our sport right so it's it's
something that affects all of us and
it
saddens us you know that
uh players have to go through
situations like that um we have guys on
our team who
compete and and and played against boko
hama um you know last year i think in in
uh in the ahl and and i remember talking
to uh to one of them buddy robinson and
and
you know he he just talked about how
really just terrible he felt for boco
this is the second time that he's had to
go through this
and talk about jordan and a lot of guys
obviously you know pk and
um
you know i played against pk growing up
in
minor hockey
i never would expect to do something
like that to to anyone um but if that's
something that unfortunately
i'm sure he had to deal with and his
brothers had to deal with and you had to
deal with anton growing up as a young
player and and i think that's what
really hits home for us as uh in our
locker room is that
um
our children
are gonna have to deal with this uh and
and we don't want young kids to have to
go through these situations how can we
be better and how can we help change
this so that um the next generation of
hockey players can
[Music]
hopefully bring this sport to a place
that uh is completely free and and
you know there's no judgment being
assessed by anyone
i can't thank you both enough you guys
have been unbelievable teammates
tremendous allies i appreciate you both
for sharing your voice because i think
hockey fans and parents and other
players need to see people like
yourselves or white allies that are
behind this that are disgusted and want
to see this end i think people
will see me enough times and players of
color will speak out about these things
but it's about time that we have allies
like yourselves that you know are
confident enough uh to be able to lend
your voice for support because that's
going to be so critical for us to
continue to change our game and make our
game a better place so thank you both
appreciate it